Threads can have many different relationship patterns. For much of the rest
of the unit, we will look at an example of the producer
consumer pattern. Before going into that however, I want to put it
in context by taking a broader view of possible thread relationships. To
give our thread something to do, we'll imagine that we are servicing
some requests that come through a queue. In the team model, we
have a pool of worker threads that all look in the queue,
fetch the next request, and service it. This idea of a worker pool
is common to many patterns. The costs of creating a new
thread are fairly high, so rather than spending time creating and
destroying threads, applications will simply let the threads wait around until
there is work for them to do. A model similar to
the team model is the dispatcher model. Here instead of having
a whole team of threads constantly looking at our queue and
possibly creating some contention, we have a single dispatcher thread looking
at the queue. He finds an available worker and passes the request
off to the worker to be serviced. Instead
of dividing up the work by requests, it's also
possible to divide it up by subtask. This is
the strategy employed in the pipeline model. One thread
DQs a request, does part of the work,
and then passes it on to another thread who
does part of the work, passes it on, etc.
So, all three of these models are commonly used.